although the Rumblings about the way the
Scottish national party has been
operating its finances have been going
on for months now at least 18 months the
police investigation has been underway
Central to all of this is the power
couple at the top of the Scottish
national party until very recently
that's Peter Morrell the chief executive
who was in post from the year 2000 until
March of this year and of course his
wife Nicholas sturgeon who was the
leader of the Scottish national party
from 2014 until uh just uh until
February now the allegation that the
police are investigating is that it's
essentially a
allegations of accounting irregularities
there was around 748 thousand dollars
worth of funds that were raised uh in
supposedly to be ring fenced for a
second Independence referendum to be
operated but when the party finances
were laid out in accounts form that that
money appeared to be missing so the
police have been investigating for
months and months now exactly where that
money went and how it was uh how it was
accounted for